[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
thank you
live from New York this is Biz Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from New York City and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored from
the Big Apple not lying politicians are
nothing new Boris Johnson famously
fibbed with impunity Donald Trump
definitely has a problematic
relationship with the truth President
Biden tells some absolute Whoppers too
although frankly it's always clear if he
knows he's doing it well my guest
tonight might just top a lot Congressman
George Santos elected a Republican
representative here in New York last
November has been branded the biggest
liar in the history of politics I've
called him out for this repeatedly on my
show so you can imagine my surprise when
George Santos agreed to sit down with me
right here in New York earlier today for
a one-on-one exclusive interview about
everything what follows is an
extraordinary interview in which I take
on one of the most infamous political
figures in the world right now Whopper
by Whopper I asked him why lies
I'll humor you this I ran in 2020 for
the same exact seat
um for Congress and I got away with it
then
I'll take him to task about falsely
claiming to be Jewish
they'd always say I'm I was raised
Catholic but I come from a Jewish family
so that makes me Jewish
he didn't come from a Jewish Family I
asked him if he wants to come clean
he left a detailed voicemail saying that
he was going to get a baseball bat bash
my husband's brains in and I was going
to watch it then he was going to
Splatter mine all over the floor and he
wasn't going to stop until there was
nothing left
extraordinary Revelations from an
extraordinary figure it's a riveting
interview with a man who's fibbed his
way to Global notoriety and it ends up
being something more like a confessional
I've been a terrible liar I mean would
you be prepared to say that sure like I
said well I've been a terrible liar on
those subjects
so was he a Wall Street Hot Shot was his
mother in the Twin Towers on 9 11 did he
graduate from college was he a
volleyball star at that college did his
grandparents survived the Holocaust is
he even remotely Jewish in a moment I
take George Santos through every one of
his lies one by one but first here's a
quick look at the self-declared
embodiment of the American dream
who is George Santos I'm George Santos
first generation American son of
immigrants George Santos to me is a
bunch of Lies it's been a bad week for
George Santos
or as he calls it a good week he's a
pathological liar my grandparents
survived the Holocaust
[Music]
embellishing is saying you've got an A
when you get an A minus lying is saying
you you graduated from a college you
didn't even attend I never said I was
Jewish I said I was Jewish actually guys
I'm Jewish remember I was raised
Catholic truth is I'm a part-time Jew
and someone has to explain George Santos
I someone has to explain this phenomenon
in case you've been living under a rock
my mom was a 911 Survivor she was in the
South Tower and she made it out
I am George Santos Miss dewalder if
you're nasty
the whole country is wondering what is
the truth about George Santos
Santos well I feel like I know you
um you've become this extraordinarily
well-known Global figure albeit not
necessarily for the reasons you may have
wanted how are you dealing with all this
attention you know Pierce becoming even
well known wasn't ever uh uh a desire
right I ran for office to be a
legislator not to be a quasi celebrity
as we jokingly say all the time
Washington DC is Hollywood for ugly
people but right uh it's it's just been
an adjustment but just trying to get the
work done look the media is going to
give me all this coverage what I'll do
is I'll use it to the advantage of
uplifting my legislative priorities for
the American people so that's how we're
we're I'm going to try to use that to my
advantage at this point how are you
dealing with the complete loss of your
anonymity now what's it been like for
you to be George Santos on the streets
in America well it's it's uncomfortable
uh think about it this way just last
night we my husband and I went out to
the movies and you know as I'm walking
from getting the tickets to get to the
concession stand to get to the theater
that's your s it Whispers all across the
movie theater so it's just very strange
you know because part of you like it as
much as part of he finds it
uncomfortable I can't stand it and a lot
of people think I love it I just can't
stand it it's something I'm going to
have to learn how to deal with because
as as you said earlier when we were
talking uh before taping once that Genie
is out of the bottle right you can't put
it back in so you need to learn how to
live with it and just that's what I'm
doing if you'd known what was going to
happen to you in terms of the ferocity
of the attention you know you're
currently you've got eight different
official investigations into you you
know people have called you the biggest
liar in the world you know all this
stuff if you'd known what was going to
happen would you have still wanted to
run for office absolutely not absolutely
not so me running for office was me
trying to be a good servant to the
American people me giving back what I've
been able to to reap as a reward from
you know this is the greatest country on
Earth and I know we can disagree agree
to disagree on that second greatest we
succeeded so I think we're it's the
greatest country on Earth and I'm very
thankful for it so I just wanted to give
back but if I knew that it would come at
this cost of
sacrificing my safety at many cases and
and my honor uh my privacy I wouldn't
have done it
like I said you're well known now around
the world in the UK people know you but
it's not for the reasons like I said I
suspect you would have wanted
let me just ask you I guess directly who
is the real George Santos I mean you've
even used a number of pseudonyms in the
past
um who is the real George Santos so it's
a it's a great question my name is
George Anthony devolder Santos pretty
long name
um and I've gone by Anthony my entire
life almost because my mother called me
Anthony I was her chosen name dispute of
parents of what to name the child so I
ended up with two first names two last
names but George Santos is I'm just a
regular person Pierce I'm flawed like
every other human being I've made
mistakes I've made strides I've
accomplished something that not many
people are able to accomplish which is
to come from abject poverty and be able
to make something and work something out
for themselves I have to sit down and
endure people say things about me that
are absolutely not true or they're just
making out of cloth because it fits a
narrative or some desperate journalist
trying to make a career off for
themselves off of my name today this is
what I've I've become subject of
desperate journalism journalists trying
to build a journalistic career for them
let me stand up for the media please do
you've also been subject to proper
interrogation because you're a
congressman of course you're one of the
most important political figures in
America as any serving congressman is
and what the media has done is they've
looked into your background looked into
your life and they found a number of
things which simply aren't true
and we'll go through some of it a little
later but I'm not sure blaming the media
will fly particularly in your defense
because the media's done its job you may
not like it it might be bruising it
might be ferocious I don't I think when
the American Media come for you as a
politician there's nothing quite like it
in the world outside of the probably the
British media um so I'm not pretending
for a moment it's been easy for you but
I do think it's a bit lame to blame the
media they've done their job and you if
I'm honest have made it easy for them of
course look I'm not saying they're not
doing their job there's a difference
between doing their job and a difference
between making a Witch Hunt out of
something
the moment the story broke from the one
from the New York Times it took me three
days it was right around Christmas after
on the 26th of December I sat on with
the New York Post had an hour-long
interview they decided to go out with
barely any if anything of what I told
him and just continue to go under the
down spiral assumptions I've tried to
sit with many members of the media like
I'm doing with you now and have a
thorough conversation but they're just
not interested they're not interested in
covering de facto what actually occurred
what actually what are facts well I am I
am and all I would urge you to be is you
may as well be completely honest now of
course because I don't see there's any
upside in continuing to fuel the media
narrative that you're this terrible liar
right so you know I'm very I listen I
don't have a horse in the race I'm not
an American citizen you're not my
congressman you don't serve me it's not
my hard-earned cash going on supporting
you so in that sense I'm slightly
detached from this all I can say is in
the UK we're aware of you because
there's been this constant running theme
now for months on end that you tell a
lot of Whoppers as we would call it in
the UK and so I think it's a good it's a
good chance Congressman to just try and
work out where the truth lies because
why not
um
there's a claim that you said you
attended the Horace Mann school in the
Bronx New York during your first years
of high school but had to leave in your
senior year because your parents fell on
Hard Times in 2008. is that true Did you
attend that school I attended it for a
brief period of time and then went back
to the public school system and then
dropped out of the public school system
and attained a GED I was always very
truthful of not completing High School
due to financial difficulties I mean
spokesman for the school told CNN
there's no record of you ever attending
why would that be I I challenge to see
what their what name they're looking
under if you look at my entire history
of education it was not under the name
George Santos so what name did you
attend that of a variation it was either
George devold or Anthony the volder I
wouldn't know I was a minor I don't know
what you're CNN I believe checked all
the variants of the names that you've
used and there was no record the school
could find of you ever attending I was
there for six months of ninth grade in
what year would that have been uh 2000
four so for six months you were
indisputably at the Horus man school and
then moved into and then moved into the
public system and then in 2006 I
attained a GED due to just circles why
why would the school not be able to find
a record I don't know uh what what name
should they be looking for I would say
George defolder that's how I that's how
it's on my uh GED certificate when you
get on the George devilda Anthony
defolder well officially the only two
names I've ever used on documentation
has been George defolder or George
Santos so there should be a record of
one of those at that school of course
the second claim was that on the on the
campaign website that you graduated with
a degree in economics and finance from
Baruch College in 2000. I'll say I'll
save you the I did not attain a college
education that was that was that
regrettably so is one of my biggest uh
uh regrets in life so that that was a
lie absolutely and I admitted to it and
I've I've made peace with the fact that
I made a bad choice in making that
decision it wasn't easy what's the
simple explanation for why you met why
would you lie about something like that
expectation on society the pressure
couldn't afford it I decided I wanted to
run for office although I had built a
very credible business career and I just
didn't have that part of my biography
that I could not give anything because
you don't think that you'd be cool
you know
I just went with it I I didn't I mean if
you're gonna make up a lie are you
thinking at all I just think it was a
stupid decision in my part very stupid
decision that I regret every day
especially because I can so sorry to cut
you off but especially because I can
prove the chops and the backing without
the education but this stems more deeper
into the political apparatus and the
political culture of New York State and
that would take a lot more time than
this program to go over to explain it
I understand the desire to want to be
more impressive with your record than
you are I I'm bemused that you would be
naive enough to think that you could run
as a politician in New York in
particular and not expect to get what
happened to you which is a massive
comeuppance when they discover this
stuff isn't true stupid
stupid
well coming next did George Santos lie
about his mother being in the Twin
Towers on 9 11. that's coming up
[Music]
guess who's back in town live from New
York City Piers Morgan interviews one of
the most controversial and influential
voices in American politics Ben Shapiro
today you accuse me of standing on the
graves of the children that says how
dare you I've seen you do it repeatedly
Pearson the lawyer who took down a
prince David Boyce Jordan Peterson
Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
all new Piers Morgan uncensored live
from New York City
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture
there's no subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Phelps on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel note
what are you uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
foreign
State Building here in New York you're
watching me live but we're going to go
to the second part now my incredible uh
interview with notorious political liar
George Santos a New York congressman who
a little earlier today sat here as I
asked him about some of his more
controversial Whoppers one of which
perhaps the worst of which if it turns
out to be untrue is that he claimed his
own mother was in one of the Twin Towers
on 9 11. but was she you claimed on your
resume to have gained a Masters in
Business at New York University
with a GMAT of 710.
I I which would which would indicate
academic Excellence but that's not true
right well the reality is I don't know
where that GMAT comes from I I never put
that out on my website or my bio but you
didn't get a Masters in Business no no
but I'm just saying that the GMAT was on
your resume I think which the resume was
never furnished or supplied by me who
supplied I have no idea where that came
from someone did it on your behalf I'm
not saying no I I didn't Supply it and
nobody associated with me supplied it
that came from the GOP and I'm still
trying to understand where that came
from but you never got a Masters in
Business at New York no it's not like I
said no right
I mean again did you not think people
would find this out you know Pierce not
after I you're not wanting to be like a
reality TV no no I understand you know
if you if you were going on Celebrity
Apprentice which I went on right it
doesn't matter you can embellish stuff
about yourself nobody cares right but to
run for Congress of the United States
and to
just tell blatant lies about even your
academic record I'm just struck not
necessarily that a politician would lie
but that you would think no one would
find out well I'll humor you this I ran
in 2020 for the same exact seat for
Congress and I got to wait with it then
and I guess
why well that's honest stupid so you
thought actually they don't they're not
going to find out no I didn't think so
but to to that effect
um it's an embarrassing it's it's
humbling to have to admit your faults as
a human being and I you know I wish
genuinely if the media put the equal
amount of efforts and resources and I'm
not saying this as villainizing the
media but just let's keep it fair on all
435 members of the house and 100 members
of the Senate I think the American
people would have more clarity of who
represents them in Congress I'm not
saying I'm not going to say I listen I
think the media both at local level and
National level have pretty well been
forensic about everyone that's in
Congress right I mean maybe not to quite
the degree you've had to sustain it
because they knew with you they had
basically a wounded animal and if they
kept going long enough they've already
found a load more right you know it's
human nature I mean you also claim to be
a Wall Street Hotshot who worked at
Goldman Sachs and Citigroup your CV
again your resume boasted a doubling
revenue on a project at Goldman's is any
of that true so I this is where the
resume doesn't where I I can defend my
work career I work for subsidiary groups
and outside of those companies we never
worked at Goldman's all Citigroup not at
them as a direct employee but I did work
for them on the lpgp side through
conference organizing fundraising uh uh
attempts and marketing of those
functions but you weren't an employee
then you weren't no a Wall Street hot
shot right I I can argue I've done very
well in Wall Street
but not for Goldman's or Citigroup not
for not directly I mean neither of them
until the New York Times neither of them
like any record of you ever being
employed I've never worked directly for
them I was never on their books but I've
done work for them through other
companies that I work for yes sir you
can't buy a claim do you run a
foundation called friends of pets United
in New York and New Jersey that saved
two and a half thousand dogs and cats
over a five-year period that true that's
true
um but I wasn't alone in in the
operation uh I had there was a multitude
of people we were all volunteers I was
the operator I was one of the I think we
were seven Founders if I'm not mistaken
between New York and New Jersey my
advocacy in animal uh welfare and animal
rights is that stems from my childhood
I've always very compassionate towards
animals I own four dogs at home they're
all rescues to one sort I call it the
home of Misfits they're all unwanted
three legs heart murmur you know issues
like that and um now everybody is after
all the revelations about the
organization I wasn't in charge of any
of the I mean the weird thing is there
were no social media accounts for it no
time those were all deleted well there
were no the ones that anyone could find
no tax records no evidence of the
charity being registered in either New
York or New Jersey they did run one
fundraiser with the rescue group in New
Jersey in 2017. for which you charged a
50 entry fee but the group would stage
the event that had never received any
funds and I can attest that that is not
true the funds all ran through through
the group and the the post of the of the
facility was who was in charge of all of
our of our filings so this came to a
surprise as much what happened to the
tax records to the social media I I was
I wasn't in charge of any of that it was
never set up as a charity even well I I
wouldn't know that I was the operator I
was the guy putting cats out of the
streets into my car taking them together
when you say you're the operator of this
of this foundation and there's literally
no record of any of it
it doesn't doesn't there's much
credibility to your operational skills
like like I said I wasn't part of the
administrative part of the group we were
seven people everybody had their own
tasks my task was George go pick up this
dog go pick up this cat there's that was
my task go go deliver this adoption and
that that was my involvement with the
organization and I quite frankly did it
well I still get a lot of message
supports from people who adopted from
from us at During the period of time I
was involved who would have all the
records I I don't know who would have
all the right one of the seven people
that you work with uh I would assume
somebody has records
this tend to I mean I think some of the
stuff like that is an arguable Point
um potentially
some of the stuff about your family life
has caused I would say more offense if
as people believe it wasn't true and I
want to turn to something that's
obviously very personal to you and
that's your own mother
and this question of whether she was
working as you claimed in her office in
the South Tower of the Twin Towers on
September the 11th and then passed away
as you said a few years later when she
lost a battle to cancer now there is no
record of your mother Fatima devolda
ever having worked in the Twin Towers so
what's that true that's true why is
there no record of it I don't know where
people are looking or what they're
looking for but there is obviously no
because of what happened afterwards
there's a record of everyone that worked
there there's no doubt about who what
I'm sorry again well there's no doubt
about who there's no doubt who worked in
the buildings there was a full record
I'm very aware so the way the way that I
look at this and and I've I've rest this
case before and and respectfully please
I won't debate my mother's
um life as she's passed since 16 and I
think it's it's quite unsensitive for
everybody to want to rehash my mother's
Legacy uh well okay but hang on here's
what I would say to that
they're only doing that because you put
this on your campaign website I think if
a politician is going to use the fact of
his mother's death online as a result
she died a few years later it was
actually 15 years later she's going to
claim that she was in one of the towers
on the day of that terror attack I don't
think it's unreasonable for the media to
investigate that and there is simply no
evidence that your mother ever worked at
the World Trade Center at all and the
NBC News looked into this and said the
only known employer she had was at an
Imports business in Queens that folded
in 1994. New York Times said she worked
as a nurse in Brazil two genealogists
found documents that said your mother
returned to Brazil by September 2001
that she was actually not even in
America at the time she applied for a
visa to enter the US in 2003 stated in
the application she hadn't been in the
U.S since 1999. so all this points to
her not being any anywhere near the Twin
Towers on September 11th I do think it
matters because it's such an emotive
part of modern American history so I
simply ask you
did your mother work there or did you
just get that wrong no my mother was I
was 13 years old in 2000 September 11
2001 I was in the United States so my
mother was here because she had full
custody of both her children so it's
I said did she lie on her on her visa
application I I don't know I was a child
when these things were being done so I
have no clue and I have no recollection
of my mother having obtained a Visa if
she had a green card and and then
applied for citizenship later in life so
that's that's alien to me now you're
asking also things that I wouldn't know
I didn't know my mom had my mother had a
business in 1994. so I'm just letting
but specifically on the point of why
nobody can find any evidence that your
mother were to the World Trade Center at
all ever
could you just got this wrong
I mean are you telling me that I got
wrong what my mother told me I don't
know is it possible she misled you I
don't believe so she she wasn't one to
mislead me but there's no record that
she was there that day at all and
there's a record of every single person
that was in both those Towers I stay
convinced that that's the truth
well coming next Tonight George Santos
doubles down on his Century claims about
whether his grandparents survived the
Holocaust
foreign
[Music]
guess who's back in town live from New
York City Piers Morgan interviews one of
the most controversial and influential
voices in American politics Ben Shapiro
today you accuse me of standing on the
graves of the children that says how
dare you I've seen you do it repeatedly
Pearson the lawyer who took down a
prince David Boyce Jordan Peterson's
Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
all new Piers Morgan uncensored live
from New York City
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use uh every little helps for
God's sake is nothing original anymore
it's finger licking Goods I'm loving it
look let's be honest we don't have any
fancy speechwriters here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it well
that one too
[Music]
this is talk TV
live pictures of Sixth Avenue there in
the middle of Manhattan on President's
Day here in the United States this is
Morgan censored live from New York City
a little early today I sat down with
embattled congressman and prolific
Fibber George Santos and one of the most
serious claims about him is that he
fabricated an entire Jewish Heritage
including falsely claiming that his
grandparents survived the Holocaust
here's what he had to say he claimed in
a conservative podcast in May 2022 that
your grandparents survived the Holocaust
your campaign bio again claimed that
they fled persecution during World War
II and you told Fox News that you have
Ukrainian Heritage on your mother's side
now again multiple family records show
your maternal grandparents were born in
Brazil and a genealogist told CNN
there's no sign of Jewish and or
Ukrainian Heritage and no indication of
name changes along the way
so
this is the one that I I'll battle To My
Grave to the point that I've already
ordered
um those DNA test kits and I've done
four of them so far and I'm just waiting
for their returns and I'm very curious
to share those with everybody because I
grew up with with this the story was my
grandfather was born in
Ukraine when it was part of the Soviet
Union migrated to Belgium met my
grandmother in the fort in 1940 or 1941
they fled to Brazil where they falsified
a lot of their documents to claim they
were born there and now look we're
talking about a time in history where
this was a very common occurrence in the
name of survival and it this has
happened to other people and they were
able to uncover it and then apology
letters were written I've seen this
happen in the community in the Jewish
community in organizations and I I will
be that same story because I'm working
on that right now okay but you would
understand that if that wasn't true if
your grandparents hadn't survived the
Holocaust that would be a pretty awful
thing why would I play with that right
that's you know I'm one of the most
staunch pro-israel most staunch
pro-judaism people in Congress so you
claim to be Jewish but you're not Jewish
I never claim to be Jewish I've always
made I've always made a party favorite
joke pretend to be Jewish half Jewish a
proud American Jew a Latino Jew and a
non-observant Jew they're all direct
quotes from
Pierce I've always made this as a party
favorite joke and it's I've done it on
stages across what's funny falsely
claiming you're Jewish no no not falsely
claiming I'm Jewish I would always say
I'm I was raised Catholic but I come
from a Jewish family so that makes me
Jewish but again it's always been a
party favor everybody's always laughed
and now that everybody's canceling me
everybody's pounding down for about the
place just because you're not Jewish
well I never said I was I've always I
I've said you were and I would always
say but my grandparents are Jewish on my
mother's side so I'm Jewish that was
always a joke everybody used to laugh it
up I said it to a room with a thousand
people in November people were
hysterically laughing it was funny to
them they loved it I don't think Jewish
people find it funny they were Jewish I
was in a room with the Republicans
people find it funny the U.S congressman
he's a Catholic with no apparent
background of any Jewish Heritage
whatsoever other than you say you have
it no one can find it I think a lot of
Jewish people would find that offensive
I I I begged it for when we were at the
RJC in November the problem you have
Congress it seems to me is that you
admit to certain big lies and then you
deny other big lies and the problem
people have is they don't know when
you're lying and when you're telling the
truth I'm not even sure now because how
can I be like I said because you've
claimed on campaign buyers you went to
this school and this volleyball team and
achieved this degree in Big Wall Street
big hitter and all these things turned
out not to be true so when you now look
me in the eye and say well actually no I
you know I'm this is true I don't know
what to believe no I understand and that
look that's a position I've put myself
in right my credibility is what what I'm
going to have a hard time in a long road
to recover and I stand clear and I stand
certain that I'll be able to do that
okay let me ask you this in an interview
um with New York Public Radio following
your election you said you lost four
employees in the Pulse Nightclub mass
shooting in 2016 I reported on that as
horrendous but none of the 49 victims at
that Orlando Club what any of the
companies that you've named in your
biography you said you lost four
employees those are the people not not
for people who who worked for you for
employees bad choice of words and I'm
not the only one guilty of that but
that's essentially the The Raw Story of
what happened no one could find any
connection between any of the 49 victims
and any of your companies so where where
is the evidence for that I I would
venture calling the company and asking
them the people at the media have done
that no they haven't they haven't been
able to to attain any contact with the
company well nobody can find any
evidence it is true
like I said I'm reporting based on what
was reported to us that morning
you angrily denied this is another one
where it's quite interesting because I
don't know why you would deny it when it
was clearly turned out to be true
um particularly after all the fury that
had gone on but you angry deny being a
drag artist after a Brazilian drag queen
posted a picture of herself with you you
said the most recent Obsession from the
media claiming I'm a drag queen or
performed as a drag queen is
categorically false it is it's not
though is it Pierce save the picture oh
hold on I go out so so if I was a drag
queen I was the poorest drag queen in
the world because I had one outfit in
one day the shortest lives I'm saying
you were a good drag queen I'm just
saying you couldn't be dressed up and
drive once oh sorry okay there's like me
saying Julia I'm not a murderer I only
kill one I understand but Rudy Giuliani
dressed up in drag it's not a water
boundary yeah is he a drag queen I've
got a lot of questions for Rudy Julia my
point you stop in drag look here's my
point I know here's my boy why deny it I
didn't deny why attack the obsessive
media for publishing a truth because the
media is not telling the truth the media
is portraying did you imagine they are
they they're they're portraying to the
American people that I mean drag
performer career drag queen which is
offensive to drag queens by the way and
I'm pretty sure most of the drag queens
in New York well they think that here's
what they think that not just because
you've admittedly dressed up in drag but
a 2011 Wikipedia bio for a user named
Anthony devolda one of your suit names
following a successful drag career you
landed roles on Disney Channel shows
like Hannah Montana and a role in a
movie called The Invasion starring Uma
Thurman now either you did that under
your student name which you
told me you use well somebody has gone
away and created their own Wikipedia bio
using one of your pseudonyms to invent
all this why would they do that I had no
notion idea or even I didn't know this
Wikipedia page existed why would someone
invent you and pretend to be you 2011.
everyone knows who you are I'm making
this very clear I have no clue I have no
ownership of that paper though right
wait there's someone here this is this
is 12 years ago pierce my point well
those who you are I never a never tried
to be an actor never pretended to be an
actor B I was never a career drag queen
I did once I dress up in drag once we've
seen photograph but I mean is it likely
I mean again I don't care if you dress
up and drag it doesn't make any else to
me no okay look here's my question for
you a it's unlikely you did that only
once if I may be sober you can say that
it's just that only once have we got
photographic evidence right Pierce I
think it's it's it's just to me it's
almost amusing that people are trying to
fight me of being something that I'm not
that quite frankly if I were to say oh
yeah I'm a drag queen that would
probably give me a Redemption points
which I'm I'm not willing to take it
because then I'd be admitting to a lie
just to cover myself for the media so I
feel like what you guys want me to do is
admit to something I haven't done let me
tell you what I want you to do I
certainly want you to be honest I I give
it down well that's what I'm trying to
tell you well listen I think I'm being
I'm being very strict you have come in
here right and you've sat opposite me
and we're going through all this and
you're giving me answers right and
that's your credit to do it you didn't
have to so I appreciate you doing it but
the you reportedly told donors you were
a producer on Spider-Man and Broadway is
that true no I never said that not true
I never said that I'm still I'm still
trying to ask I've asked the reporters
tell me who the donors were that I
actually that's kind of got down through
I never said to anybody I produced a
Broadway show and if you look at the
Timeline I think I would have been 21
years old well you claimed a lot of
things in your life Congressman
um one month after you were elected you
claimed on a Brazilian podcast you'd
already suffered an assassination
attempt and that you described being
mugged on Fifth Avenue in 2021. I was
mugged on Fifth Avenue in 2021 was there
any police record no there was no police
right you didn't report it there was no
pull there was no police inside 2021
this was a Zombieland out here oh but
did you report it no I did not I got up
went into the car defeated upset because
I had experienced one of the most what
happened they took my briefcase and my
shoes who did two guys
that's it
I was crossing the street not fifth
pardon me Sixth and if that reported
fifth sixth because I would I worked on
the fifth on 55th and Sixth Street
you know Pierce I don't know I felt
defeated embarrassed I'm a six foot tall
guy that couldn't defend himself from a
briefcase in my shoes do you know how
humiliating that is do you know how fear
how much fear gets instilled in you I
just finished running across the street
into the garage where the my car was
parked picked up my car and left
I'm lucky my phone was in my pocket so I
could you know just do the the phone
payment on the or else I wouldn't have
money to take my car what about the
assassination attempt when was that it
wasn't an assassination it was a death
threat this is poorly translated
Portuguese to English language it was a
death threat it was several deaths
nobody tried to kill you no and I've
never claimed somebody tried to kill me
these were several we had a several
series of death threats following so
this Brazilian podcast has you saying
already suffered an assassination
attempt that's well that's been badly
translated this is poor translation so
we go back and we listen to the original
please do I I I I wouldn't have you
saying you'd already suffered I I
encourage you yeah yeah so it wouldn't
have you saying those words it has me
clearly saying that I suffered a uh um
death threats throughout the process of
running for office something along those
lines but no assassination okay here's
the thing here here's the thing you may
as well just be completely honest now
well that's what I mean I'm not going to
respond yourself to the public to their
Mercy to say I've made up all this stuff
about myself right I'm incredibly sorry
and I've fallen the sword of of your
forgiveness because you're now facing
eight different investigations who knows
where they're all going to lead there's
all these questions about your financing
your campaign campaign expenses all of
it on the face of it looks dodgy but
your biggest problem is going to be
persuading people of what the truthful
answers are I have a question for you
though and if I may eight you say
there's eight investigations I haven't
seen a formal investigation be open yet
the media keeps portraying to the
American people that I'm being
investigated through the Wazoo and
that's all I keep asking at least report
it factually just please tell the people
because what what this alludes to is
people thinking that I'm a criminal that
the doj is coming after me and then we
start receiving again death threats at
my office just two weeks ago we had
incredible death threat from a man with
a rap sheet as long as you can think of
from the state of Florida calling us and
leaving it the man was so psychotic he
left a detailed voicemail saying that he
was going to get a baseball bat bash my
husband's brains in and I was going to
watch it then he was going to Splatter
mine all over the floor and he wasn't
going to stop until there was nothing
left
or the genius left a voicemail on my
office number we sent its Capitol Police
they did their job they found him he has
a rap sheet he's been arrested and
charged hold on I I don't know where the
for the point of the investigation is
but I know who he is I have his rap
sheet the Capitol Police know who he is
this is something that's highly
concerning to the safety of me and my
family it's not the media whipping up
the anger against you there's so much
sensationalism right well that's why
it's been it's been good for Clarity on
this
one of the more serious allegations
against you I felt was that you stole
money from a disabled veteran who
contacted you to help fund life-saving
surgery for a service dog this is a man
called Richard ostoff he says that you
raise cash on GoFundMe but refused to
hand over the money and AP says the FBI
is now investigating this what is the
truth of this I've never met this man
a lot like I've been abundantly clear I
feel for him I feel for his story I am
as compassionate and as passionate about
helping veterans and animals as is the
next guy I when I read this it just it
hit me like a bag of bricks because I
don't know him and most people who know
me who truly know me Pierce knows that
if he had met me his dog would have
received the surgery he wouldn't be
homeless the fact that he was homeless
and anybody trying to help him address
wouldn't address the homeless issue was
a bigger problem for me and I mean that
wholeheartedly so you never set up a
GoFundMe page
I've set up dozens of GoFundMe we'll
find one that relates to let me make it
very clear I've set up numerous GoFundMe
Pages throughout the years for for
animals and needs many of them who were
not managed by me they were managed by
other people but because I was the main
account holder on the Facebook page it
would all go they're not denying there
could be a GoFundMe I'm not denying
there could be a go for me page but I'm
what happened to that money if there is
like I said I'm not denying if there's a
GoFundMe page and if they're going to
present me with one I'm not going to
deny that but I've never met him I've
never took on this case and I never took
the money from his dog
well next tonight the final part of this
extraordinary interview will Congressman
George Santos apologize for being a
terrible liar
[Music]
guess who's back in town live from New
York City Piers Morgan interviews one of
the most controversial and influential
voices in American politics Ben Shapiro
dare you accuse me of standing on the
graves of the children that says how
dare you I've seen you do it repeatedly
Pearson the lawyer who took down a
prince David Boyce Jordan Peterson
Superstar daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
all new Piers Morgan uncensored live
from New York City
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel nobody
is uh every little helps for God's sake
is nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at
7pm join me just do it well that one too
[Music]
well coming up on the talk Nicola
Bully's family say we can let you rest
now after the three-week search comes to
an end Prince Harry's legal row with the
home office cost the taxpayer 300 000
pounds and even the Prime Minister now
speaks out over Roald Dahl's books being
Rewritten all of that coming up at nine
o'clock
foreign
of Liberty here in New York City a great
symbol of course of freedom and
democracy and appropriate that President
Biden is today in Ukraine with president
zielinski is just left in fact but was
there this morning
defending and helping zelenski and the
ukrainians defend democracy and Liberty
and freedom good Fame
one of my last part now of my remarkable
interview with Congressman George Santos
the big remaining question really was
simply this
could I get him to apologize for being a
terrible liar
let me ask you just about your your
I guess your private life to a degree
which has been put through the mincer as
you know
um it seems from everything that's
appeared in the meeting it's your chance
to clarify this you'll now you're
married
yeah although there's no record of that
marriage having happened I'll actually
show you the wedding certificate
I was married on this on November 30th
2021 where in Nassau County so it's all
registered there yeah because no one's
found any records it's there it's and
it's there okay and you were previously
married to a woman I was married to a
woman yes so how long
it was on and off a couple of years it
was a personal private messy part of my
life and something that I refuse and I I
will not and respectfully and I hope you
don't take this personal but I will not
indulge anybody to get into my personal
life because it's irrelevant to what my
job as a legislator is my second my
personal sex life is not something that
I'm going to use for entertainment and
no tabloid here's what I would say
listen I agree with you but I would say
that someone who has made a a big play I
think of being the first openly gay
Republican who was non-incumbent to be
voted into Congress you know you've made
no secret of your pride of being that
that's about your sexuality so I think
it's reasonable for the media to just
try and establish what you're so life
has been like I never campaigned on that
ever on being gay that was all proudly
about it I when asked but that was the
media's obsession with this campaign was
oh it's the first time two gay men ever
go head to head for for U.S Congress but
I never campaigned it wasn't a campaign
issue it wasn't even a footnote on my
website obviously I was cute I mean do
you feel you've always been a gay man no
no I my life was it wasn't
straightforward I I was very much in
love with someone and we got married and
it just didn't work out
yeah did she know that you might be gay
I don't think so no
and it got messy Pierce like I said I'm
not going to rehash my sex life on
television what reaction have you had to
being a gay Republican Congressman the
Republicans have never discriminated
against me matter of fact it's the
Democrats who often come after me for
being a gay Republican and they use that
to to criticize me it seems to me I mean
you've been very honest there about your
private life
you know and I don't want to break over
it all I'm not going to do any any
further but you have been it seems to be
very honest and I would applaud you for
that but it begs the question why not be
as honest about everything else in your
life you've got a lot of people calling
you the world's worst liar and political
history wanting to trash I beg differ
because Joe Biden's in the white house
but that's just me I've seen you tweeted
that I've seen you that's just me you
know Mitt Romney one of the senior
Republican Senators came up to you
instead of uni and said you shouldn't be
glad handing people down the front you
should be out the back hiding in shame
and he also said that you should Stand
Down
wouldn't be the first time somebody told
me to shut up and go to the back of the
room Pearson it's not going to be the
last is it right though Congressman that
you should be able to have told so many
lies and remain in Congress or do you
think the American public are entitled
to somebody who is more truthful sitting
in one of the great seats of power in
the country I think that the Americans
who voted for me will get to judge me in
two years and they make that ultimate
decision not the Talking Heads not
politicians not Party leaders do you
think you want to run again I don't know
I and this has let me make this very
clear if you talk to people who knew me
before any of this ever happened they
always ask so what's next I said I don't
know if I'm going to run for re-election
that's always been a thought I I believe
in term limits that's number one number
two I came to this job I wanted to see
if I could accomplish the bare minimum
for the American people which was my
thought you come into the shop very
naive thinking that you're going to
conquer the world and you're going to do
everything good for the American people
and when you hit Washington DC you learn
that it's just not so straightforward
and that's what I want I want to be able
to overcome the political red tape of
Washington DC but what do you say to
people watching this you go all right of
course you do that's fine but what about
all the lies you've told I mean would
you stare down the camera and just
apologize I've I've looked inside the
camera and I've said sorry and I have no
problem saying sorry and asking for
forgiveness of the American people
watching at home and everyone abroad
because I think that if you can if you
can
ask for forgiveness and have the
humility to accept and admit your errors
I think that's the first step now it's
amazing how I don't get that same
courtesy like everyone else does
ever and you've been through this Pierce
it seems like there's a different
there's people who are granted that
opportunity to apologize and redeem
themselves and there's people who are
thrown into the fire pit and and the
media and everyone else around them are
hell-bound on making sure that that
person's life is hell I'm in the latter
part I don't get the opportunity to ask
for forgiveness and and gain forgiveness
from people or sympathy you supported
Donald Trump over what many call the big
lie about his stolen election I don't
think he had the election stolen from
him but have you heard from Donald Trump
no I have not not at all no
have you heard from other senior
Republicans supporting you I have many
Republicans who have been supportive I
have a great support system within the
party of people who are you know walking
me through this very difficult time in
my life and they've been you know Mitch
McConnell uh I've never met Mitch
McConnell I saw him at the State of the
Union Kevin mccarthur Kevin McCarthy has
been a great leader for the Republican
conference and he does he think you
should carry on
I haven't had that discussion with him
no can you go around as George Santos
now and persuade other politicians to
help you with stuff or are they all like
you know what just get cleared or we're
not interested so I have two bills that
we're working on right now and that
we're getting uh folks to subscribe to
and we're working on good bills for the
American people
and I'm not having a hard time I mean
it's I'm not going to say it's easy but
it's not abnormal from the difficulties
that every other politician has trying
to get people to subscribe to their
ideas
and I'm navigating the process well the
one difference between me and the
ordinary person is I come from struggle
I come from abject poverty as I've
always said so my life is I do how can I
be sure well I think that the proof is
in the pudding both my parents were
immigrants I don't know what the pudding
is oh I'll tell you what the pudding is
both my parents or immigrants I was born
in a public City Hospital in 1988 in
Jackson Heights queens in a basement
apartment where I I I beg differ that I
think the rats were bigger than me when
I was born so and true stories I've I've
submitted enough evidence on that I I
say this everything can you give the
American people you're not going to
carry online
I've I've made that abundantly clear
that I want to be the most transparent
member of Congress and deliver the most
transparent everything that goes on I
look if I'm flying stops now it stopped
a long time ago well Congressman I'll
say this about you you came in to Piers
Morgan uncensored and you face the music
and I appreciate that I appreciate you
and I'll be interested to see what the
public make because in the end it's not
down to me what I think of you or anyone
else in the media it's down to the
American people whether if you decide to
run again whether they're prepared to
actually vote for you again yep I think
uh like like I've always said this is
going to be decided by the people who
hired me not no one else so that's when
I'm going to face the music
thanks for coming in thank you sir I
appreciate you
extraordinary interview there with the
politician who knows how much of that
was true or otherwise but at least he
had his say tomorrow night David Boyce
who was the lawyer for Virginia du Frey
the woman that prince Andrew paid all
those Millions to brings his silence one
year after that settlement it's an
extraordinary interview tune in tomorrow
night
[Music]
foreign
guess who's back in town live from New
York City Piers Morgan interviews one of
the most controversial and influential
voices in American politics Ben Shapiro
today you accuse me of standing on the
graves of the children that says how
dare you I've seen you do it repeatedly
pierce the lawyer who took down a prince
David Boyce Jordan Peterson Superstar
daughter Michaela
expect exclusives expect fireworks and
expect the unexpected
all new Piers Morgan uncensored live
from New York City
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV